hello everyone and welcome to one of the
most requested games from yesterday's
Tata steel India Blitz section uh the
the second day it's Arjun eregasi versus
Hikaru Nakamura which is uh of course a
brilliant clash as uh both of them are
incredible players Arjun won a
spectacular second place in the rapid
section and now he's playing against the
highest rated Blitz player in the world
that is Hikaru Nakamura and he's already
leading by uh by by 2-0 he defeated
Hikaru in Rapid and he also defeated him
in Blitz with the black pieces and now
Hikaru has a chance to at least grab a
point with uh with black so let's see
this game features the names of Indian
it's it's uh wonderful stuff let's check
it out uh Arjun goes for D4 we have
Knight to F6 C for E6 Knight to C3 and
Bishop to B4 the names of Indian defense
is on the board with F3 the cloak
variation and now C5 we have D5 and
Hikaru castles this is all very standard
stuff so nothing new here E4 or grabbing
the full Center here and now the main
ideas for black are D6 and B5 Hikaru
goes for the sharper line Pawn to B5
idea being that if you capture the spawn
then you weaken your D5 Pawn then just D
captures sorry he captures on D5 e
captures on D5 and Rook d8 check and
white is already in trouble it's very
hard to defend you have a pawn and F3
you have to play some like Bishop to E2
or or Knight day two or King to F2 and
while it might be playable it doesn't
really uh make sense to give black hole
this Advantage so after B5 Pawn to E5 uh
pushing the Knight back Knight to E8 and
now Pawn to F4 grabbing even more Center
e Captain d5c captures and pawn to D6
now we have Knight to F3 and uh Pawn to
C4 there are many moves that have been
tried in this this position but C4 seems
to be the strongest one uh A4 attacking
this expansion uh Hikaru created on the
queen side and now Knight to D7 we have
a captures and B 5 the characters on E5
uh and now Bishop captures on C4 with
Knight to D6 now attacking the bishop
and Bishop back to E2 and there is a
game where Queen to B6 was played but
here we have e characters on F4 by
Hikaru and it is now as of move 14 that
we have a completely new game uh so
Arjun castles uh his King uh does one
overstay his welcome and now Bishop to
B7 here it seems that the best way for a
car to play this is just to push G5 and
to defend the F4 pawn and uh make uh
Arjun Arjun work for his meal here but
after castles and Bishop to B7 origin
just picks up the F4 pawn and now white
is just a little bit better he does have
the past D5 pawn and the black doesn't
seem to have any real real counter play
here Knight to F6 we have Bishop to D3
Queen to D4 is even stronger just uh
pure centralizing move with the queen
forces Bishop captures on C3 but okay uh
this is Blitz after all Bishop D3 with
Bishop captures and c3b captures and now
Knight captures on D5 and Hikaru is back
in the game he eliminated that beautiful
pass Pawn okay he uh White still has a
past C Pawn uh but uh you know the the
D5 Pawn was very nice with Bishop back
to D2 as the Knight was attacking it
rooked the C8 and now Queen to C2
putting pressure on the H7 Pawn so Pawn
to H6 and now c4
advancing that pass pawn and Hikaru goes
Queen to B6 with check interestingly
Hikaru doesn't spot Knight captures on
C4 it's just a free Pawn because the
ones white captures it you're gonna play
Knight to B6 and you're gonna win the
bishop now uh but okay cargo's Queen to
B6 with check we have King to H1 and now
Knight the E3 forcing a trade as the
queen and Rook are hanging so Bishop
captures an E3 Queen captures and now
Rook 8 E1 uh very nicely played by Arjun
grabbing the open E file for his Rook
Queen back to C5 blocking those pawns if
you allow C5 and C6 then black is just
lost so Knights the E5 now and Rook F
the E8 we have Queen to B2 and now Rook
the C7 preparing to double up on the E
file uh Knight the G4 uh we have Rook C
the E7 and we have a trade captures
captures on E7 and here you should play
Queen to F2 or for a queen trade and the
game just continues so maybe he called
Trace maybe he does doesn't either way
it's good for both white and black but
in the game H3 was played and H3 loses
the game on the spot why this is so I
mean yeah okay you you create some
bringing room for your king but I'm sure
you guys realize it now but just in case
you don't feel free to pause the video
and win the game for Hikaru while I give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting that the
Knight has no squares and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is Pawn to H5 Knight the E4 is also very
nice because the G3 square has been uh
freed up by the the advancement of the
Ponte H3 but H5 is even stronger so
congratulations if you found either of
those moves pointers uh that now after
uh let's say you move the Knight and
there really aren't all that many
squares you can move the knights too
like you can go to F2 but then comes
Queen G5 and the queen from G2 from B2
is no longer defending the maiden G2 so
you have to move the Knight again let's
say Knight D1 and now Queen G3 and white
resigns that's the problem of H3 now
you've set up uh this Fork basically the
queen is attacking the bishop that's
undefended on D3 and also Queen captures
on H3 is the threat as the G Pawn is
pinned so here you would just resign and
also at night the H2 isn't all that
better you're just gonna play pretty
much anything The Rook can and come to
E3 you're gonna be able to capture here
the Knight can come to E4 to G3 uh a lot
of stuff is winning here but in the game
uh Queen to F2 was played now Arjun
offers a queen trade and it's a very
nice offer because now if Hikaru trades
then the Knight Will capture and the
Knight no longer has to be worried about
about the H Pawn but here Queen to G5 by
Hikaru absolute strongest move Knights
the H2 and now Rook the E3 Hikaru with
the only winning move attacking the
bishop and the H3 Pawn so Pawn to H4
attacking the queen now Queen to E5 and
here we have rooked the D1 defending the
bishop and Hikaru goes Knight to E4
which is not winning for him the the way
to win this is to play Rook H3 and it's
uh you you have to see a few moves ahead
which is not easy if if you're very low
on the clock which which both of them
are uh point is that now Checkmate is
being threatened and The Rook is still
uh not hanging because the bishop just
pins that G2 Pawn you're gonna have to
move the king to G1 and now Rook G3 and
there isn't all that much you can do
Rook D2 maybe to guard the the G2 Pawn
but not just Bishop captures on G2 and
after Rook captures Rook captures on D3
and you've completely uh busted open uh
the white King's position this is no way
to defend your your king uh so black
will win this very very easily but in
the game Knight the E4 was played by
Hikaru and now look at this bishop
capture Sunny four Queen captures and
now Knight to F3 and now everything is
defended the H4 Pawn is defended the E1
square is defended and no longer you
have to worry about this diagonal so how
can Hikaru play this well it's uh it's a
position where uh Hikaru should force a
draw with Rook captures on F3 uh you
can't capture it right away if capture
it right away then black just wins as
you win that uh Rook on D1 but what you
can do is after Rook captures an F3 you
can move the Rook with Rook to d8 with
check and out after King to H7 now you
take the Rook uh G captures an F3 let's
say queen captures on C4 and the game
continues uh with uh chances for both
sides of course this is Blitz they they
have a very little time uh but uh you
know with with uh some decent play
should be a draw Hikaru goes for F6
instead and now he allows Arjun to start
advancing his pass Pawn but he doesn't
do so just yet he goes for Queen to G3
and now we have Queen to E7 uh Hikaru
doesn't want to allow any any Queen to
be a check idea so he goes Queen to E7
and now Rook to F1 we have rooked the E4
and now Pawn to C5 Arjun says all right
capture my pawn and I'm gonna play Queen
to B8 with check but this doesn't really
do anything and the Hikaru trust
Sergeant here because if he captures and
queen the B8 with check you can just
block and I mean black is just much
better now so instead uh Bishop to D5 by
Hikaru he doesn't want to get his Bishop
trapped and now we have Pawn the C6
rooked Rook the C4 now putting the Rook
behind the pass pawn and now Rook the E1
going after the black queen on E7 and
here you have to play Queen to C5 or
queen to B4 but after Queen to d8 by
Hikaru now Arjun just plays Rook to D1
and now the bishop can't really move and
the queen doesn't really have many
squares uh from where she can defend the
bishop here Hikaru plays Rook to C5 uh
to defend the bishop here and now we
have Queen to F2 going after the Rook
now again this is all Blitz and I will
show you a winning line because it's
just uh too spectacular not to show but
the winning line is Queen to G6 and it
looks odd but then you realize What's
Happening Here uh White's next movie C7
uh pretty much regardless of what black
does let's say you play Queen to B8 as
you really don't have many moves and you
want to get your queen away from that D
file look at this C7 and now if the Rook
captures you lose the bishop on D5 and
if the queen captures well then you have
the back rank Queen to E8 with Chuck
King H7 Queen captures an H5 with check
king j8 queen to E8 with Chair King H7
and now Rook captures on D5 Rook
captures and now look at this queen to
E4 with check that's the that's the
whole point of of the queen having the
G6 Square uh you can just you know
triangulate however you want and now
after King the h8 queen captures on D5
this is not actual triangulation in
chess you just moved in a triangle
that's why I called it but this is not
the actual triangulation in chess uh
it's okay I have to look at the C5 we
have Queen to F2 by Arjun and now Hikaru
can bounce back a little bit he should
play Queen to E7 which gets the queen
out of Harm's Way from D file and also
defends The Rook but he goes for Rook
captures on B5 and now we have uh again
Queen captures on A7 is winning but
Arjun plays Knights to D4 first he goes
after The Rook uh Bishop characters on
C6 Hikaru says all right you can have
have your Rook I'm not having any of
that but here Rook to C1 now just the
uh really threatening that because as
long as the Rook is on D1 and you
capture then Queen capture Sun D1
happened so Rook to C1 and now Hikaru
plays Bishop back to E8 what you should
probably do is play Bishop captures on
G2 but none of it is like winning for
black it's just that maybe it's going to
be very hard for for white to defend now
Queen D5 check King G1 and now you move
the rook and yes whites up a piece but
the black king is white in the open it's
not gonna be easy against the queen king
and a queen rook and maybe you can start
pushing your past Pawn but in the game
Bishop the E8 was played and now Knight
captures on B5 Bishop capture Sun B5
Queen captures on A7 and now this is a
dead draw pretty much because the the
white king is so wide in the open but
Hikaru played one of the few moves that
blundered the game on the spot he played
Bishop to E2 and now I'm sure you guys
know what's happening here even without
pausing the video as I mean look at this
uh this is the the price of playing
Blitz and being the the highest rated
player in the world sometimes you you
will just Crush everyone but sometimes
you will miss a nice Fork like this so
Queen to A2 was played a check was
delivered and it was in this position on
move 47 that Hikaru Nakamura resigned to
the game and Arjun arigasi uh one not
just one game against Hikaru but three
games like we said at one time in Rapid
and two times in Blitz which is
absolutely incredible as Hikaru is the
number one he's the highest rated Blitz
player in the world the only player uh
aside from uh alirez affiruja who is
over 2 900 at the moment now in the live
ratings list this isn't um
so anymore if you guys are interested
this is the live ratings list of the uh
of the world Blitz rating so now you can
see Hikaru dropped 25 points he is now
in second place and now alireza is the
only 2900 player in uh in the world in
in Blitz uh then we have Hikaru karwana
Carlson only in fourth place uh uh
arunyan Artemis
in the Arjun education climbs up to 10th
Place uh so he's world number 10 when it
comes to Blitz at the moment on on the
live ratings list then dude grishock
martirosi and Wesley so Enrique and
Anand
uhmediar those are the top 20 currently
uh so yeah uh that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it uh it could have gone
either way I mean uh Hikaru had a
winning position but uh you've seen how
how Arjun just persevered and and uh
Hikaru could not uh you know just take
him down grab a full point and that's
what uh what Blitz chess is that's what
uh what uh what kind of a fighter you
have to be in order to win games uh at
this level
uh so yeah once again hope you guys
enjoyed it I would like to thank Zoltan
sarkodie Eric Adams the animated
chemistry textbook uh KGB Sellers and
ante booty gun for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here and thank all
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing uh well not the coverage the
the tournament is over but I'm gonna
show a few more games if you have any
favorites do you do use hashtag
suggestion and I will go over it and
basically whatever else is happening in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day and in case I forgot to
mention Arjun won the blitz section yeah
in case I forgot he got second place in
Rapid won first place in Blitz uh second
place in Rapid only half Point behind
nihal sarin uh see you soon